[Laughter]
okay
let's get into the headlines of uh the
nerdy news of this
ah i like this i think uh john you
brought this up some reddit sleuths have
kind of uncovered that there's been some
uh
writers hired for agatha house of
harkness they've been listed the project
is uh is being readied for airing in the
2023-2024
television
and the listed genre
is dark comedy hey now what's an example
of a dark comedy
uh berry berries oh barry is ready
oh that's i think even the boys is
offensive
action comedy for sure uh i'm trying to
think historically like what what was
because i mean like barry is pitched as
a comedy that has very very very dark
moments
uh
what else do we have we had uh recently
that was an older show yeah yeah
yeah if there's themes of like dad gonna
die like uh what was it uh nurse jackie
was kind of a dark comedy on uh
i can hear you
atlanta's a dark comedy i guess it is
what kind of crosses genre but yeah okay
i'm more just trying to figure out like
how disney would do a dark comedy so
like when hearing pushing daisies i was
like that one's a light-hearted one so i
think disney could touch that no no
maybe we're not there
especially in that first episode or two
of loki there were definitely a lot of a
lot of the stuff set at the tva felt
kind of dark comedy ish
right um but but anyways we're
fascinated because we have no idea what
the show's gonna be about we're gonna be
coming back to it later in the episode
it might make an appearance in
mandatory fun
i have to whisper it if i say it out
loud it brings it into being that's true
yeah we don't want to wake the mandatory
fun
mandatory fun beast
some of the
co-workers on the slack have said we may
want to recap the first 30 seconds of
the show because we were a cacophony of
echoes okay great idea is still a
cacophony no i think it's been solved by
our master technician john john thank
you he was so busy being on camera um uh
okay to quick recap instead of uh our
normal chat redemption today when we hit
a multiple of a hundred dollars in super
chats we will be taking a drink it's
it's a true happy hour break room today
um the kind of thing that normally gets
you fired from your job today we are
being forced to do it
next next headline in an interview with
the playlist will poulter i think that's
how you pronounce his last year was the
actor playing adam warlock in the
upcoming guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
you might have seen vander snatch movie
uh
did tommy just pop up
we're just drinking as much as we can
before tommy needs no no redemption
sometimes you're beyond redemption boys
and girls
sometimes it's just over listen to me
real quick brian henson
[Laughter]
tommy goes through those cold domestics
like uh so much uh wheat and chaff there
um but will poulter uh playing adam
warlock said in an interview he'd like
to take the character on a journey
through multiple films uh which again
it's a recurring theme any mcu actor is
always like i'd love to do 10 of these
movies please uh why not i'd like to do
five series and uh i think
oh sorry i was gonna say do you think he
grabbed a good character like after
hearing uh benedict cumberbatch was like
i almost took the villain in this other
movie versus doctor strange do you think
he chose a good character yeah what hold
on
i hope he does comics wise adam warlock
a lot of different ways he can go lots
of involvement he can play in a lot of
different worlds he's a major you know
uh he's been around he's been super
powerful
anytime you're a highly powered
individual i think you're putting
yourself in a good position yes he could
get his own spin off he could get his
own spin off i think there's a great
chance like all mcu movies set in space
he he can show up he can guest star he
can cameo all the way i mean look at lee
pace doing guardians one and then coming
back from miss marvel like true ronin
the accuser not gone gone but not
forgotten brought back forgettable again
though
we were just talking uh we were just
talking pushing daisies that's right
this is gonna we're gonna keep pace with
lee
all show long as many pace references as
you can
hey tommy if you keep doing that i might
ask you to halt and catch fire okay
the first eight minutes of stranger
things have been released online i
haven't watched it because i kind of
want to absorb the entire uh series on
its own um and we're not going to talk
about what it shows but uh that's kind
of become a thing lately where you
release like the beginning of something
who who pointed out that they did that
with sean chi right yes yeah i think
what brandon did in our morning meeting
um
but no they do it a lot they did it
because they what was the other ones
they did it with shangchi
they did it with oh they
oh yeah more combat did too didn't they
do
maybe not the worst
there was one of the disney plus star
wars shows i could have sworn they
showed us like maybe it was only three
minutes maybe it was something i i swear
we got an extended view of maybe mando
season one i don't know i think so too i
think so i agree with you i think it was
mandalorian but i i i snapped because
they did with one division remember the
the scene where they're in the bed
together oh yeah
noise yes yes america's boss and i were
like what does it mean
and i gotta say i don't love it as one
of those people who's like god trailers
give too much away i want to be
surprised in the movie but if you're
going to give us any extended scene i
like that it's the very beginning so
then the whole rest of it you can be
surprised three i think trailers are out
of hand me and kevin feige basically
contemporaries and defines on the same
intellectual level we both want to see
less in the trailers i would love there
to be a person which i'm sure there is
someone on twitter or somewhere that
tells you that watches the trailers and
then tells me if it tells me too much
yeah because i wish i would have known
that with the boys season three yeah
yeah a politifact rating of like this is
mostly lies or this is mostly truth what
do they do pinocchio's
is that their thing now
um uh speaking of clips we got a new
kenobi clip
john are we going to be able to play
this
[Laughter]
there's more to life than your farm owen
he needs to see that there's a whole
galaxy out there i'm asking you
to leave us alone ben i mean it
is he okay
you don't care if he's okay
you care if he's showing it's my
responsibility owen i'm his uncle we
talked about this when the time comes he
must be trained like you trained his
father
okay
[Music]
a quick round of applause we had not
planned to have either yesterday or
today remote there were unforeseen
circumstances a whole bunch of stuff
forced us out of the office so kudos to
john if you think this show is a little
bit of a mess imagine what it would be
like if you weren't busting this hump
for the last two days to try to make it
happen
yes
okay internet the internet went down at
our office and that is why in which we
are working from our own homes he said
that it might be some blank air time i
guess i am your translator i'm going to
speak for it i will be john jc for jc
i'll be your voice person
i'll be your morgan freeman yeah
i'll be here
i'll be your private dancer you're
dancing from the answer for money
[Music]
you're crying shoulder
i'll be
love suicide
i love that i love this clip and we got
the very end of that i think was in the
full extended trailer right with him
saying protect him like you did his
father right
oh such a great line um what do you
think what do you think owen knows about
obi-wan and anakin's history at this
point
that's a tommy question i mean
he knows he was supposed to be taking
care of anakin and he knows that anakin
is oh does he think anakin's dead i
don't i always get confused about that
is owen aware that anakin is darth vader
or does owen think that anakin died on
moose to far
um
oh
me and bro i wish brandon this is what i
brought me and brandon just talked about
this yeah brandon i know you're watching
just a message in the chat yeah chat
well and granted super chat us put a
little bit okay yeah brandon throw your
paycheck in there buddy um
maybe and maybe if not
he thinks he directly killed him he
knows he's he was supposed to be looking
out for him and whether anakin is alive
or he understands that he's darth vader
he knows that right he did not fulfill
his responsibility to look out for the
kid i'm going to find out first i'm
going to ask hayden christensen if he's
that celebration next week i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get it from the horse's mouth
again a big tease both uh tommy and eric
are gonna be at star wars celebration at
the end of next week a week from today
you'll be there that's right uh as
special kind of vip guests uh as
demanded by lucasfilm head kathleen
kennedy herself
sent a handwritten note to eric and
tommy um
can you tell us who's speaking are you
able to tell us that or is that oh yes
no though i mean i can tell who's
announced we've got a uh
disney plus series preview all series
all-encompassing uh panel on thursday
which is uh filonia will be speaking
along with favreau and they're the
speakers and then they say and many more
special guests which i can only hope
casa kenobi cast of ahsoka cast of mando
season three would be my dream however
maybe not mando season three because
saturday the panel is all about mando
season three and again only felony and
favorable are built but friday
they have lawrence kasdan and ron howard
and and many other directors and writers
attached or affiliated with previous
star wars films getting on stage and
discussing the creation process of star
wars uh films and tv shows and i am very
very excited for that one and vos and i
will both have a chance to uh take that
in so stay tuned we're going to try and
report back as much good
uh second question can you bring a
camera in uh can you
record i actually had my body modified
by thundercat to have multiple cameras
everywhere so
i'm always recording i'm gonna have
those bruce wayne from batman uh contact
recorders yes i would imagine because we
are i think technically under the
umbrella of press right
there i mean there might be a no cell
phone thing but uh maybe at least a tape
recorder i don't know if not you should
live tweet you should live tweet yes
and we're gonna try to get some some
content out of tommy and eric while
they're there next week yes absolutely
um i also like uh
somebody pointed out in the chat
the um is he showing
line in that quote like is is luke
starting to like
show a little element of his force
sensitivity or something like that is
really a weird quote
um
okay but oh we've we've also got some
daredevil news jessica that you want to
see
yes we do the hollywood reporter has
reported that the upcoming daredevil
disney plus series will be a
continuation a continuation of the
netflix show uh good news for the fans
of
netflix defenders and all those shows
because they've been irritated if this
wasn't a continuation uh i say i can't
say continuation correctly
which i think was like the first
we were all ecstatic when we heard the
news but i think our first immediate
response was is this canon
is it gonna be connected because if it's
not i'm gonna be upset so with that
being said will this officially be set
in netflix daredevil or will it be set
in the 616 mcu oh
i am hoping that it is 616 mcu if only
for the selfish reason of i like all of
my
uh
toys in the same toy box like i don't
want to have to care about a different
universe i like put them in 616. if they
bring
i feel like it has to be 616 because
they're now jumping into the disney
territory but
if they do acknowledge it's in the six
one six don't we have to start
acknowledging like the punishers in the
six one six no i'm saying i'm saying
that this show can be
charlie cox deborah anne wall uh elden
eldren hansen whoever else
has their 616 counterparts because we
know that matt murdock is a practicing
lawyer in 616 as we saw spider-man far
from home or no way home rather and he
has the abilities to catch a brick out
of this guy so we're assuming he got
some of his training is already done if
not all of it the only thing we don't
know for sure is if he has his armor
right we don't know if he went to what's
that guy's name gladiator or whatever
the guy that makes his armor
i forget what that guy's name is it's
something but anyway uh let us know
colin if you know uh
but uh
what about you zach do you think is it
six or netflix i i think six one six i
agree and i think they'll do it in a
specific way where like it's been it's
also been how many years since that last
season of daredevil right was that 2018
i was gonna say four or five when it
first started or when it ended oh sorry
final season
um but it's been long enough right that
a the characters will have grown changed
and anything they don't like they don't
have to mention ever again right i don't
think like tommy said i don't think
they'll recast any main actors they
won't pretend like those seasons didn't
happen but you can kind of just like
soft
continue here do stories you don't have
to worry about the baggage of those
previous stories use it to your
advantage but also like this this series
will need to be able to be enjoyed by
people that didn't watch any of the
netflix series exactly sure that's what
they'll aim for
okay i i
this is a hot take
i like when stories do that
um this is a hot take because i like
that you could just throw people into
the series and be like yeah you might
not seen it when it was on netflix but
you can now watch and still not be as
confused this is mainly a shout out to
my mom who i want questions continuously
yes
as mine as well hope you're both
watching go see hawks go bills now oh my
god i want to see
jennifer and foggy in a court battle
against each other over like you know
just some small claims so we think that
they're still gonna be
in the show like all those original
people i don't i thought foggy couldn't
be in it
but
did he die
deborah and we'll also be yeah yeah
deborah ann okay we need to go back and
watch the livestream i never watched the
last season of daredevil i guess yeah
exposed you know i just the first time
until you said his name out loud that i
thought the actor elden hansen henson
who played foggy nelson has anybody made
a dear elden hansen joke oh
anyways i'm done
[Music]
oh so do we think foggy karen and even
elektra could return because of this
series oh oh give me a lecture
yes
some justice for elektra there i think
it'd be great and i think like if if
this is coming back on disney plus and
now disney plus has not shown a huge
appetite with their marvel series of
like having them go multiple seasons
right so far loki's the only one that's
been confirmed for a second season but
some of that might be
actor contracts
you know different priorities it does
feel like and no shots at any of these
people this cast might be down to do
multiple seasons absolutely multiple
seasons almost all of them have come out
in public and been like i want to keep
revisiting these characters i love this
show they're not previously established
movie characters reverting into a tv
show like i think the big thing of like
why we haven't seen a confirmed falcon
captain america series yet it's like
there's a captain america four being
made so like you don't need to make or
not falcon captain america winter
soldier and captain america
sorry about that but you know what i
meant
[Laughter]
so i guess okay so everyone in the chat
is asking for begging for electric just
saying elektra number one what about the
defenders what about the rest of the
defenders
i think the punisher
should show up again is that is it just
me is it just me his scene when he was
on trial is probably the best scene to
ever hit mcu acting history
i love elizabeth olsen i love that actor
i love that character i would be more
than fine to have the punisher come in
i'm not sure i think we have to wait
until deadpool debuts in the mcu or
deadpool 3 we see how that is received
by
kind of the
uh disney sensitive mcu fans that maybe
missed deadpool one and two and then
things like the punisher kind of open up
no that doesn't mean that that character
or that frank castle can't show up in a
small way but in order to get his own
you know regular presence i think we got
to kind of see because the closest to
that we've really had is a character
like crossbones right not not
necessarily morality but just like a
straightforward kind of killing
also john bernthal is so great
and
anybody watching we own the city or
whatever that new hbo uh series he's
just even his scenes in uh king richard
if anybody saw that it was so good
he was so good in that movie so playing
against his type right and it just
really opened up for me that he can kind
of do anyone anything i've been
vindicated i have audio
now
also this show might be the cry for help
that we needed because nobody wants us
to drink they're like you know what
the drinking instead of we actually want
you guys to be okay i will be doing
drinks
that they were into me drinking or no
they said that jessica shouldn't this is
going to be a mess because okay you know
what
i can't see where the
super chats are at but i assume
they're still pretty loud
this is a pro sobriety audience yeah
this audience is this is temperance it's
not funny a lot of people a lot of
people in the chat though are asking uh
they're happy that john's back age
to give like big reactions to things
that it it was bad content yeah where
was where was that improv at john that
was silent silent film actor john costa
there he is
a lot of people are saying jessica jones
a lot of people are saying jessica jones
and let me tell you right now
one from one jessica to another jessica
we've been big i'm begging for it you
all want jessica jones back jessica
jones was my favorite one and then luke
cage of course actually
luke cage versus daredevil they were
both so good they were both so good it
was just i love kristen ritter she's a
great jessica jones so yeah i would love
jessica jones to come back and this cute
but i want her own series i wanted to
get her own series again absolutely
great character who knows maybe this
daredevil series could be like we could
get some cameos from some of these
characters why not what if it is kind of
a soft defenders
uh season even um
speaking of soft defenders um
we want to thank our friends at baksu
for helping us bring this show to you uh
tommy was able to get out of our no
internet having office a boxu he's got
the midori moments box i believe oh
special millennium falcon delivery
oh baby do i have a box suit for you
i've got the midori moments collection
and of course boxu is the monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
straight from japan
to your door each baksu features a new
theme providing a gourmet journey
through japan and the midori moments box
that tommy has midori is the japanese
word for green
and this collection is inspired by
japan's uh spring rainy seasons
got a look at this green tea cookie
right here a little biscuit i'm gonna
eat that later there's some mochi
there's some wasabi covered peas
i don't know what the heck this is but
i'm gonna
do something with it later i don't know
it's kind of weird
i don't want to hear about that i'm
gonna eat it i'm gonna eat it oh uh yes
the boxes all kinds of green snacks like
matcha cakes and wasabi crackers and of
course green tea
um
all all shades of good spring green it's
a perfect time of year it's a little
overcast in los angeles today so it'd be
a nice day to pop in some uh green tea
um we've been
gnashing on boxes all week spread the
love eric had some yesterday the whole
cast had some monday and tuesday uh you
should get yourself a box so it's also a
great gift particularly if you have
somebody in your life that loves anime
somebody who took a trip to japan once
somebody who likes uh funky little
snacks or loves to try new stuff jessica
checks all those boxes she's pointing at
herself big anime fan
i'm dying to go to japan but i need to
do another fitness challenge because
every time i go to europe or asia i'm
reminded that like things just aren't
built for giant americans there and i'm
like i need to like figure out a way to
like squeeze in and really enjoy but i
gotta say these boxy boxes i was
basically like going to japan if you
only went with your mouth which
most of my trips one of the most fun
parts about traveling is eating and uh
and also that little booklet that tommy
showed off has a little bit of the
history and some background information
on the people that make these snacks a
lot of whom are small family-owned
businesses that have been around for a
really long time it's a really beautiful
uh booklet so it's a little educational
you learn something about snacks and
japanese history and culture um so to
get one for yourself or maybe to send
one to a cool friend or loved one or
family member
click the link in this video's
description and use code rockstars to
get 15 off your order that is not only
getting yourself or your loved one a
cool boxu snack subscription it's also
helping us out here on the break room we
appreciate you much appreciation john
costa showing some appreciation for the
new rockstarsmerch.com
can i see it i can't see it i'm sorry i
am
oh
you can purchase that at new
rockstarsmerch.com
whistle uh limited time on that guy
that shirt that that it's not a gendered
shirt i don't know why i called it a guy
it's a guy it's a girl it's whatever you
want it to be um insects it's a unisex
that's right though i think it actually
is it offered in universe i think it
this is the universe sex version there
might be a woman's version as well i'm
not sure you get two i get all mine baby
doll cut so i can tell you that i don't
know that they offer that one yet but uh
that's right but uh grab one of those
quick because when we release those
latest obsession shirts they're kind of
they go along with the property this one
was for multiverse of madness and they
don't want last that much longer after
the property is gone like i think the
moon night shirts already sold out that
that bad boy is not long for this world
we'll probably have an obi-wan shirt
dropping sometime soon new
rockstarsmarch.com
ah now tommy we whispered its name
earlier hang on awakening from deep
within the bowels of chateau bechtold
a stirring
a nightmare a terror
a dreamscape a revelation a miracle it's
time for mandatory
graphics going yeah that's great
we do it twice this is where i take my
three best friends and i ask them to
have a little mandatory fund with me and
they say is it optional and i say hell
no it's mandatory fun you gots to do it
so
we all found out were you gonna say
something jack well tommy i was just
gonna ask you always say it's your three
best friends but this is the first time
john's been here now did he bump
somebody right okay right i actually who
did he bump i have a secret
i'm currently broadcasting from san
francisco last night i snuck into eric
voss's apartment you will no longer be
seeing him on the new rockstar's youtube
channel he's being replaced
you heard it here first voss replacement
i'm about to burn down my own house
right now john
we just lost 1.7 million
i don't know i don't know we'll win them
we're going to get them back
philip is still working on that skin
suit ai for eric we'll have them back in
no time we're going to get it back hit
the ground
now it's a mandatory drinks y'all
well you know what we can't because we
set a time limit and we're not going to
drink unless you pay
okay
it's not going to happen now we all
heard earlier that egg at the house of
harkness
father-son and house of heartness uh is
going to be
uh
a dark comedy which quite frankly isn't
life a dark comedy if you give it enough
time between sadness
uh anyway i have decided that i want to
see
tommy's drinking what
tommy's drinking yeah we got there and
the the fifty dollars was from bailey to
you so you have to take this shot really
you gotta take this job baby my pleasure
wait are we all doing one right here
also we got uh bailey did 350 bucks
thank you for your support
tommy i know you got my bag of toes it's
hard to walk you're not using them
please return them bailey those toes
were a gift i'm keeping them
we appreciate you nabeel and we'll
cheers to both of you both of you bailey
and nabeel
oh it burns so good
you can't take shots at gym you can't
take shots at gin that's not possible
why did i do that how can i ever do that
zack and i have a meeting with philip
about the future of the company after
this this is about are we on the
shopping block yeah yeah if not all
right you know what
let's make this the best mandatory fun
ever then guys
agatha house of harkness
a dark comedy what's happening i forgot
okay
it's gonna be a dark comedy and that
made me think what if egg of the house
of harkness was greenlit in like 1991
what kind of sitcom would that look like
so i want you all now to pitch
your versions of agatha harker house of
heartness in a classic sitcom farm
unfortunately guys i feel horrible about
this
i can't be here what to hear oh no
tommy we can't lose you i did find
someone to take my place he's like oh
one of them he'll probably be a good
person one of hollywood's hottest
executives uh
he's all about town his his job is kind
of indescribable his industry
is is unmeasurable where he's influences
oh is it wayne brady guys
it's my good friend t michael beck told
him he'll be in just
i wanted the mass singer wayne brady but
i'll take t michael every time t michael
shows up it is absolute chaos that guy's
egomaniac super chat of 9.99 from the
spirit life that says eric boss that's
right that's right the breaker
the break room is the premiere content
on new rock stars
baby i hope you don't mind
i have my son gideon with me for the
weekend
gideon this is time you learn daddy's
business now
each of you
will pitch to me
agatha house of harkness as a sitcom
the pitch i enjoy best
will be green lit
and moved into production
who would like to go first gideon
gideon
uh i i can start us off uh
t michael also i i assume you're saying
you only have your son this weekend that
you are no longer with gideon's mom uh
no gideon's mother and i are very
happily married
gideon's on a full basketball
scholarship to the university of
anchorage
oh yes
wow all the way up in alaska huh he may
not look it but he's a savant from the
follow line okay
awesome
it's all starts with fundamentals but
you can't have fundamentals without
mental fun
oh well that's that that that pivots
nicely t michael into what i want to
talk about okay last we saw agatha
harkness right um
you know
wanda kind of
kind of wipes her memory a little bit
kind of re-hexes her brain to make her
feel like she's kind of permanently
stuck there so i want to pivot off of
that this series picks up right after
that
jason bourne style okay
agatha doesn't realize she's one of the
world's most powerful witches okay so it
manifests in strange ways she's able to
kind of summon things accidentally make
things happen almost as if just by
wishing them and slowly over the course
of the series remembers her powers comes
back into them
right and then maybe regains a little
bit of them black fingertips that that
uh uh ill intent but
i think the title house of harkness it
makes me think of one of our favorite
movies of 2021 house of gucci
uh
by morbius himself jared leto
uh the gaga
uh and so i think agatha i once spent a
holiday weekend with gaga
in the hot suns of tempe
working on our farmer's cans
michael you get the wildest stories
uh so i think agatha again jason bourne
out of out of her memories not really
knowing everything not being able to
remember uh the true nature of who she
is will go to work at a uh devil wears
prada ask
fashion magazine wow okay maybe it's
house of fashion maybe it's something
like that and we and as she's you know
there's a little bit of ugly betty to
this
kind of the uh the outsider the ugly
duckling this weird uh 200 year old
woman who's at her memory wiped
goes to work at you know the high
fashion magazine is maybe interacting
with co-workers that don't get her
there's some
fun butting of heads a fish out of water
comedy and slowly as she comes into her
power she takes over the publication she
takes over the entire fashion world wow
i love it
also pointing on the chat yes i am
drinking out of a bartender tool
a little uh alcohol measure thing oh i
am i'm actively reading the chat you
guys um
and i'm dying because someone said
gideon skipping leg day
and then someone said someone said who
needs legs when you fly to the hoop
that's right
gideon has more bounce to the ounce
what's that boy
well he can't just be all arms zaddy
zach has ideas too
as well as those piped up cannons who's
next i'll go i'll go next um
so
i i like where you started your story
zach i think we should pick up right
after the events of wanda vision wanda
has just sort of uh re-hexed agatha and
has put her under her spell but i think
it should go a little differently i
think
what is more
dark
than giving agatha a little bit of a
taste of her own medicine hear me out
we see the prototypical
american dream house right white picket
fence
uh you know two kids um uh and it's
agatha and ralph and two
kids they have to raise together
in like a full house type situation and
there are all these you know sort of
family members coming in and out and
it's just like agatha is trapped in what
she sort of took away from wanda and
it's like got comedic moments but it's
also like deeply deeply messed up
because it's like this mind prison that
agatha can't escape and she's sort of
being tortured by sort of you know what
she took away from wanda in essence she
knows it's fake but there's all these
like
people in her life that think that she
is her mother or her sister or whatever
and she's just like stuck in this fake
reality
well whatever happened to predictability
because you just blew mine and gideon's
faces off that edge
good jessica
good [ __ ] luck sorry
hey there's no swear jar today good luck
everybody that's right we can
does that mean we can just swear
whatever we want i think so someone said
boss is gone john is there and then baby
hey
up with the boss and in with the boss
that's right baby
um
okay so in my version or not even my
version how i think agatha house of
heartness will go
is agatha we at last see her right she's
now just a normal like
like a normal woman in the suburbs
correct correct black and white like old
school woman in the suburbs right
so everyone's like whatever happened to
her she changed she changed crazy so she
goes back to school am i right listen
hear me out hear me out why don't you go
back asking us if we know the answers to
your pitch
i don't want to participate
get in get in getting in he's going to
be
he's starting to dribble his little
basketball now
all right i'll i'll go quicker with my
pitch i'm sorry maybe gideon just
doesn't like it's okay it's okay so
she goes back to school you know she's
trying to learn she goes back to school
everyone's like dude you act different
you're so crazy you're wild and she's
like yeah and as she's going to school a
lot of stuff keeps happening to her that
keeps reawakening the witch deep within
her so she starts getting more into
witchy things and people are like oh no
she's getting back into old habits but
then she meets white vision
white vision at a party who goes on
and when she meets white vision at a
party that goes off she's like that's
the one i'm sorry i actually am gonna
ask her question yes
does white vision
go off
i can't disclose
this right now
because and i know what you guys are
saying in the chat jessica why does this
sound a lot like euphoria and the thing
is
this is also written by the same person
that did you for you
uh
i don't know that euphoria is a dark
comedy but you know what oh god it isn't
oh i forgot that we were this was a
comment i thought we were doing dark
sitcom challenge gideon and i need a
second to deliberate give us a moment
please okay sorry my bad
whoa
it's a big old marathon
all right
t michael didn't have any limits to when
he would drink his
that was the worst thing i've ever heard
uh i'm sorry i can smell it
t michael
now
i've been in this business
38 years i'm getting slack messages
from people
this has to stop
this has to stop
listen to me
i know one thing about this business
and that's
moving tv shows
and selling episodes
and when you brought back full house
john costa
your first episode of the break room you
headed out of the park
we're ordering 98 episodes on my
streaming service slim oh it used to be
slime but we lost all the rights to the
e's it took the e's from us we got sued
by e-network so we're just slim now
now you're on our streaming service 98
episodes of ag at the heart in his full
house gideon get out of here
whoa
oh nice work john
thank you
wow a 98 episode order what is this uh
house of pain
on tps
first off i love housing
on fx
uh i i'm still sh
tommy never invite t michael beck told
back oh no was he fell on the air
why would he do that
you know what guys i'm sorry he promised
me he was here for one reason and one
reason only to develop a new television
show and i trusted him and i thought
this was a great opportunity for you
guys
i'm so sorry guys i i honestly
from my gucci to your moochies
i'm so sorry
i
apology accepted on behalf of t michael
tommy thank you the tommy tommy bechtel
puts his fist over his mouth when he
belches t michael just
flips it right he just let it fly
uh we've got you guys get to meet his
son
gideon yeah i miss godfather oh oh
quite a little hoopster that giddy
really
we heard um we've got a couple uh super
chats and other uh chat messages we want
to answer real quick richard medina
saying go bills go brody
people should know i have worked at new
rock stars longer than tommy beck told
and it
pains me to say this i am a jets fan and
every go bills
just a little piece of me dies slowly
are they both in the same state
well no because the jets claim to be
from new york so if they play in new
jersey
well i i i i don't know sports john i'm
so
john you asked a very pertinent question
because there is only one team that
plays in new york and that is the
buffalo bills and all other new york
teams claiming to play there are liars
and frauds horrible they're playing the
meadowlands yeah in new jersey uh also
john uh
no dis to your jets but the bills are
the unofficial official uh nfl team of
the break
um
also shout out to that guy you know
tommy i didn't realize you've worn both
uh steven brody stevens and
uh brody lee
you have shirts for both of them you
wear on a regular basis well brodie lee
near and dear to my heart uh lived in
webster new york his kids went to the
school where my mom taught uh i hate to
be serious after that insane mandatory
fun segment but uh yes brody lee i love
him very much uh he was an excellent uh
contributor to the community and a very
fun professional wrestler and by all
accounts an amazing person brody stevens
the hero of the valley gone way too soon
uh also a person i worked with and uh
was i guess acquaintance because every
time i saw him he would ask me where his
money was for a job that i had no uh
responsibility to pay him on where's one
but i do miss him because we don't all
have to take another shot because they
reach another hundred yes
this shot this shot will be in honor of
uh both brodie lee and stephen brown
stevens i do hate that you're using like
a normal bar shot glass
i just moved and i can't find any of my
other glasses in honor in honor of the
brodies to the brodies oh
both good guys taking too soon taking
research
um
patriots no sorry foreign michael's burp
guys i already regret it and it's caught
on the internet forever now
nick alexander saying yeah do you think
daredevil will be cameo city i think
that'd be great oh hell yeah i spent a
long weekend in cameo city with lady
gaga once i don't know
you know we were working on your
farmer's team
no that was team michael when we were
talking about this earlier i do think
like there's room in that sort of like
hawkeye side of the mcu to have a bunch
of these defenders peoples come in we
have the echo series coming out soon i
think we could see
a bunch of defenders characters in that
show um i don't see why they wouldn't
just start kind of trickling these
people in to you know familiarize the
disney plus audience myself and
admittedly did not watch the netflix
defender shows to some of these
characters i think that's a perfect
opportunity to do that
yeah i and and even some of the disney
plus characters we've been introduced to
why not right like they've now kind of
built out a very deep roster a deep
bench uh and we've seen even with emil
blonsky showing up in chongqi and now in
she-hulk right they're willing to go way
back to pull some of these folks in i
love the cameos let's do it um
bubsy monkey boy phoenix
love that name yeah do wanda's actions
in multiverse of madness mean that
agatha kind of won
i don't know that kinda one is the right
take but like was kind of right right
he's probably yeah
right
remind me correct me if i'm wrong and uh
i apologize for doing any kind of
analysis at this point but i uh at the
end of wanda vision
agatha kind of like resigned herself to
the fact of like well she's the scarlet
witch she's like if she wants to
like originally i was just trying to
like kind of like you know keep like
figure out what was going on with her
because wait she she found wanda because
she sensed her magic right like that she
was drawn to her then once she figured
out that she was a scarlet witch she
tried to like
thwart her and then once that jig was up
she was like okay well now i just got to
try not to get killed by her so i don't
know that necessarily she got like she
was justified i think her survival is a
victory certainly well in jumping
you know we talked the other day about
one of the deleted scenes from
multiverse of madness about mordo going
to the orchard and wanda killing him
that was a scene that eventually you
know didn't make it into the movie but
with mordo's line of uh
too many sorcerers or whatever it was
that's a little bit of vindication for
his maybe dead
um character in the house of year two
that like he was right he was right with
all of the variance strangers who were
off the rails and now wanda you should
have been taking them all out
right
absolutely and i love that shade of gray
right it's a little bit like those
motivations aren't that different from
defender strange at the beginning of
multiverse and madness wanting to like i
don't trust you america with your own
powers so like i need to take them i
mean those motivations aren't that
different from agatha not that defender
strange was you know the best guy but
like we kind of side more with him than
we would with somebody like agatha yeah
jessica
thanks teach um did you turn your chair
around and sit in it so my mom uh i
looked at my phone really quickly just
briefly sorry john looked at it briefly
mom texted me she said stop drinking
my mom said keep watching right now um
my mom said are you sure you don't have
to drive anywhere no
she's a [ __ ] she's a big sports fan so
she's seeing all the chats about the
sports team and she's like no one's
saying seahawks i said go seahawks
she remembers that time you said that we
don't have a quarterback and she's like
he's nice but i remember that i
apologize to her direct listen to me
i said i was sorry jim hansen
anyway sorry sorry to derail the
conversation this is what happens when
you drink a little bit on on
and real quick nicole angeline shouting
you out in the uh super chat that belch
was impressive i think the belch was
polarizing frankly there were a few
people that found a little less than
impressive let's start the pull out hey
dodson let's get a quick flash pull up
on it
thank you guys for saying hi jessica's
mom in the chat she is
live texting me what you're saying
i don't know why she's doing this i will
say
the show has gone slightly off the rails
it sounds like tommy's so drunk his
mouth sink is stopping um is is no
longer working so thank you guys so much
for joining us on this episode of oh
we're done i know i know zach and i have
to get to another meeting and we need
like five minutes to cool down um but we
really appreciate you guys being here
with us while we're remote we're gonna
try to get back in the studio as fast as
we can um but have a great weekend uh
thank you guys for tuning in
thanks for catching up thanks for saying
hi to my mom hi linda
[Music]
street
you